-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Oh, that's so good to hear
Let's get to the news.
The Biden administration
has reportedly run out of idea
to encourage more people
to get the coronavirus vaccine
Luckily, the virus is coming u
with new ideas all the time.
Vice President
Kamala Harris yesterday
praised Texas House Democrats'
plan to leave the state
ahead of a Republican-led effort
to pass a restrictive
new voting law.
"Hey, I was leaving Texas
way before it was cool,"
said Ted Cruz.
Fox News is reportedly
planning to launch
a 24-hour weather channel
later this year.
Finally, branching out
into something
where it's acceptable
to be wrong half the time.
It was announced on Sunday
that Tesla CEO Elon Musk
had purchased a ticket
on a space flight
from Richard Branson's
Virgin Galactic.
Well, Elon, don't be nervous
If you drive a Tesla,
you're statistically more likely
to have an accident
on the way to the airport.
Today was actor Harrison Ford'
79th birthday.
In the next
"Indiana Jones" movie,
he searches
an ancient Egyptian temple
for the glasses that were on top
of his head the whole time
[ Laughter ]
[ Growling ]
[ Growling ] "Here they are.
[ Laughter ]
Mattel yesterday released a ne
Barbie doll
of tennis star Naomi Osaka
and the Barbie doll of a
reporter is already mad at her
New photos were
recently released
from the
"Sex and the City" reboot,
which follows the characters
lives into their 50s.
And so far,
it looks pretty accurate,
because they have fewer friend
now that they're older.
That's right,
the "Sex and the City" reboo
follows the characters' live
into their 50s.
It's pretty much the same,
except Carrie accidentally
types her whole column
into the subject line.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, officials
from a Minnesota city
have asked residents
not to release pet goldfis
into ponds and lakes
after they discovered
a fish the size of a football.
And, you wont believe the size
of the castle they found.
And that was the monologue
you guys,
and quite a fine one,
if I may say so.